[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down
[Music]
June the movie is filled with a ton of
details that I think we need to talk
about as well as a deeper meaning to
what's going on now as of making this
June part two is out yet and thus I'm
keeping things locked solely to this
film therefore we're not going to spoil
any of the big reveals for that and
instead I'll keep that separate for its
own big breakdown make sure you
subscribe to so you don't miss that and
if you enjoy this one then please hit
the thumbs up we do big breakdowns out
this every week and will definitely
become at least your fifth favorite
Channel on YouTube but please just give
me 70 seconds of your time whilst we
shout out our sponsors and then get into
the breakdown gather around Seekers of
quick Triumph and expedited victories
Behold a realm where Simplicity is the
harbringer of Triumph I'm sounding like
the games master and that's because we
here to talk about Monopoly go it's a
brand new way to play and board flipping
cleanup is no longer required ired
experience Classic Fun and visuals with
gameplay fit for your phone collect
properties build houses and hotels pull
chance cards and of course earn Monopoly
money play with your favorite game
tokens such as the race car top hat
Battleship and more earn tokens as you
go and watch Monopoly come to life with
brand new characters too I love mobile
games because they allow me to escape
when I've got a free moment with
Monopoly go you can experience the
reimagined world of Monopoly Guided by
everyone's favorite zillionaire Mr
Monopoly they've got new boards themed
after world famous cities Fantastical
lands and imaginative locals monoply go
has got the classic fun with modern
gameplay and it allows you to experience
the classic Monopoly with visuals
tailored for your phone I'm D to get
back to it and if you guys want to play
as well then just scan the QR code on
screen right now you can also click my
link in the description and I'll take
you straight to the app or scan the QR
code to download the game now Monopoly
go let you become a tycoon for the day
forget the risks and investment so just
have fun and yeah dive into the game
thanks now in order to start this
journey we need to go back way back into
time that takes us to the year 1965
which is when Frank Herbert released the
book to her massive success great
success immediately everyone saw the
film potential with Arthur P Jacobs
locking down the rights that gave the
producers N9 years to make a movie but
sadly passed away during
1973 74 hit and with nothing being made
they were then acquired by Jean Paul Gib
bringing in Alejandro jarowski to direct
they then started on creting the movie J
he looked at the names at the time and
tried to get as many prominent figures
included as he could Salvador D was
going to play the emperor with Aon Wells
playing Baron HW Conan Paul trades will
be played by some brontis MC Jago was
going to play Fade sting ended up in the
role for the David Lynch one and it's
kind of funny how two musicians ended up
playing the Pod jarowski also looked at
musicians at the time to help create the
soundscape and hands him actually gave
an N to this during the production he
sampled Pink Floyd for Eclipse which was
then used in the first first trailer for
the
[Music]
film one day the legend will be
born all of civilization depends on it
however as with most projects trying to
adapt the book they found out early on
it was n on Impossible thought to be a
14-hour epic that was just too much for
this to actually get made you see the
thing with June is that if you've read
the book or listen to the audio book
you'll know that the movies they they
miss a lot out the source material has
lots of different threads and directions
that you could potentially take a film
and a writer has to weave those threads
together to create one straightforward
plotline I'd say it's like if you took
the Song of Ice and Fire books that that
were made for Game of Thrones but try to
adapt them into a 2-hour film sure
you're going to have your main character
potentially in someone like Jon Snow but
you're going to miss out a lot of what's
going on therefore it's a challenge to
adapt and that's why pretty much every
adaptation focuses on Paul now according
to the wiki the work didn't go to waste
and elements of it ended up an alien
none other than HR Gea was behind the
designs of both and in his concept off
for June you can see shades of really
Scots Masterpiece looking at the
Landscapes and the xenomorph itself it's
easily identifiable in the suits used in
the film the skulls and elongated heads
are there as well with sand worms also
being echoed in the film now 1976 is
when a big change came about and Dino de
lenes purchased the rights that Year's
extremely important as we of course had
Star Wars in 1977 it's often thought
that if any of these adaptations had
beaten Lucas to the punch that the
landscape of Cinema would look a lot
different about the Space Opera epics
but it's in the tone where the pair
differ whereas Lucas took inspiration
from June it ended up being a fun and
upbeat
movie hello there June on the other hand
was always intended to be well well June
and and it was in 1978 that they got a
screenplay together the novel's auor
Frank Herbert but was commissioned to
write the script and in the end he
turned in a three-hour long treatment
Ridley Scott was hid in 79 with HR G
coming across as well here they wanted
to split the buck into two parts which
is of course something villain of also
ended up doing struggling to adapt it
though the production moved to slow and
Scott ended up going over to direct
Blade Runner instead the rights were
then renegotiated with lentus buying
them up again and hiring an up incoming
David Lynch Lynch was H off the back of
the Elephant Man and at the time also
got offered Return of the Jedi however
he ended up going to June after reading
the book and falling in love with it
Lynch originally wanted two films as
well but this was condensed into just
being one movie running at over 4 hours
he was forced to cut it down and we
ended with what I I describe as a
hatchet job a longer version was
released for TV and we've of course also
had the film dropped on physical media
if you want to see it then make sure you
pick up the arrow 4K and in case you
don't know bit of spam but we've
actually partnered up with them if you
go to the site and use the code heavy
spoilers guess what you get 10% off just
go to my link in the description and use
the code heavy spoilers Ed a presto
you'll get 10% off tune either way
lynches said it's a bit of a sore point
and that he's got zero interest in what
villain of's doing seriously man you and
mean we're [__] done professionally
and that's not because he's a hater mate
calm down but he said all it's going to
do is bring back painful memories he
said it wasn't the film he wanted to
make and overall it makes him feel like
a failure Lynch was never given Final
Cut and he was forced to condense major
parts of the script B server was brought
in to try and explain the plot holes and
it's clear that Lynch didn't have much
of a say during the release he was also
in the middle of working on a second
script as there had been plans there
were going to be two sequels however
once the movie bombed it was kicked to
the curb and moved out the way faster
than the atres we then got the Sci-Fi
miniseries in 2000 which actually
actually isn't too bad if you want to
learn the law unfortunately it didn't
have a big Blockbuster budget but that
in all its sequel should get you filled
in on on the story then we had the Lord
of the Rings in Harry Potter films both
of which managed to adapt expansive
works this made Paramount think they
could finally make June and in 2008 they
brought on Peter BG this fell apart and
in 2011 Legend rebot it which led to
what we got today banov was hired in
2016 and he's gone on record saying how
much of a fan he is Denny said he loved
Lynch's film and followed all the making
of stuff when he was a kid apparently
used to obsess over hearing about in the
fantastic film magazines and read
through the novel when he was 12
according to I trivia he actually held
off jumping on the film as he wanted to
direct some Sci-Fi movies first to get
experience in the genre known for
prisoners enemy and sakario he held off
until after doing arriv Ral in Blade
Runner 2049 that takes us into the film
itself which like a lot of the other
adaptations split the book into two
however legendary new Dune was a risk
and thus I didn't want to film things
back to back a sequel was option but it
depended on the performance with which
we'll talk about after we wrap up the
breakdown however meant some things had
to be excised including characters like
fade who W on present in the film this
was because I didn't want to waste time
on things that would distract from the
story here and we begin with this
message before we get the
logos this is some sakar throat singing
with it later being repeated when we go
to that
[Music]
planet there's lots of potential ways to
take this quote with Paul streams being
lace throughout the movie all of these
help to H out what's going to come and
in many ways they hold symbolic meanings
in some he sees channy and in other he
sees jamus who can be seen winning their
battle at the end why is Paul dreaming
of his death especially when this is
something that doesn't end up happening
why don't you explain this to me like
I'm five well the way I take it is that
this is Paul witnessing his death or
rather the symbolic death of the man he
used to be in every person Paul kills a
part of himself dies which at the heart
of it is what June's about Jamison some
can also be seen as a teacher which may
symbolize his death showing away that he
can become a fman leader all Ates Must
[Music]
Die to rise this is the line that stands
out to me the most and Paul a traes must
die in order for the quizat Hada toise
also I'm probably going to mispronounce
things in this video cuz they changed
the pronunciation depending on what you
read or watch and yeah I'm going to try
my best but just bear in mind if you're
writing a comment about have
mispronounced it it's it's probably all
it's already too late for me to change
it it was a quiz at had a give a dog a
bone now there's even been theories that
this voice at the start is Leo II
looking back on the history of his
family spice allows one to see about the
past and future with one being able to
tap into their family's genetic memory
there are theories that our own DNA can
affect our personality with us being
Guided by the ancestry that helped to
shape us the Deep could refer to the
history deep within us that Spice in
itself allows us to tap into strong
Theory either that or it's just a great
way to grab your attention with this
popping up before the film's logos the
quote doesn't appear in the book so hey
maybe maybe that's why as well it's just
a theory memes are messages from the
deep dreams of course also have a double
meaning as dreams can often mean
someone's goals this in the end will
make him lose himself and it's the cost
that it takes to be the boss when you
take a life you take your own I think
villain of what was smartest started off
this way as Tunes pretty complex when
you get into it it tackles languages
religions different houses prophecies
technology and also politics so going
with dreams it just simplifies it down
and gives us a thread that we can all
easily relate to one of the major
criticisms about David Lynch's version
is that the cutdown film was pretty
incoherent so in order to avoid this the
movie's about Paul's goals in which he
becomes a man fit enough to lead his
house now one of the big differences in
June compared to other science fiction
novels at the time was that there wasn't
the technological predictions that they
had for Humanity those were filled with
laser guns people typing in a vast
computers hanging out with robots but
all that stuff it's completely absent
from the work Herbert hints towards what
may have happened to push us from this
with them actually predicting where
Humanity would go next he stated that
once humans started relying on computers
that the Men Behind These computers
would then enslave Humanity now whether
that's the case or not it's something
you can argue but I'd say there's
definitely an element of Truth there
it's a ones who run our technology
social media and what we see they're the
ones who hold all the pieces predicting
that back in the 60s it's eily chilling
and it's what helped to shape the design
of the universe the text doesn't
necessarily explain what happened in the
war but it does touch upon what's known
as the but larian Gad this came when man
overthrew machine and the idea that man
should not be replaced pretty much
became LW so you can't have Androids or
computers running things and instead
Humanity turned to spice this perception
altering substance opened up our
Consciousness and allowed our minds to
go to the next step this is why we see
people like the mentats who are able to
carry out computer like calculations
just within their head normally a Menat
starts taking spice as a child and this
allows them to gain position in a house
this will normally be somewhere where
they can provide Cel and thus in the end
it's a coveted position you see every
planet is ruled by a house and all of
these originate from Earth the tradies
began their life in Greece and as we
learned they were in fact Matadors the
name of Trades plays on King Of trus Who
was a prominent figure in ancient Greece
fighting a bll was a labor of Hercules
and we also had the myth about the
bullheaded minitor there's also bull
models and icons Lac throughout and on
the grave the Juke visits at 13 minutes
we can catch a bull and matador this is
the grave of Paul's Grandad paulus who
as we learned died during a bull fight
we can also catch Grecian letters on the
bottom tying back to their Origins on
Earth in many ways it's impacted how
Duke approaches things with them also
saying and Grand father fought bulls for
sport
yes look where that got him a huge shout
out to now playing podcast who pting out
this shows that he shouldn't rush into
combat against something that can wipe
him out in many ways however this leads
to his downfall as in the end the Duke
isn't brutal enough your eyes I need to
see it in your eyes you never met Harkin
as me before I have they're not human
they're brutal now in the novel june
house at Tres we learn paulus was
betrayed by his wife Helena who had a
hand in drugging the bull the Haw conens
themselves could even be seen as
metaphors for them with them blindly
charging in and taking out the Juke
according to the wiki the bull fighting
sculpture we see was created in order to
enforce his double meaning made by Luke
Massi he wanted to use the ball to show
the house har Conan the word Hawker also
means ball which is why it was picked as
their enemy the Mador itself would be
House of TRD and the cape would
represent a rakus as for the houses that
they're difficult to infiltrate as you
either get into one in one of two ways
one can either be born Through Blood
light or marry into it and become a
family member I'll talk about that more
in a bit but beyond that spice also
allows for Interstellar travel this is
what helped Humanity Journey Through the
stars with a spacing Gill leading us up
and the side effects of spice are that
it makes your eyes blue but it can also
cause someone to mutate it takes a vast
amount in order for that to happen but
the spacing G leaders are all something
else we don't fully learn exactly what
that is until June Messiah and in the
book Paul sneaks about the ship trying
to see them before making it to a racus
later on we learn there people that look
like fish which evokes the idea of them
swimming through the starts that's where
we jump to after the logos and we join
channy describing a people's conflict
the first person we see is jamus before
we then pull up to see channy beside him
these are two very important figures
that will in many ways take Paul to the
next PATH and we learned spice is the
most valuable substance in the universe
with oracus being the only place it's
produced thus the one who controls it
controls the universe which means the HW
conans have a master Fortune built on
the Bloodshed of the fman it's said that
they're richer than the emperor himself
in this opening we also meet the Beast
who's played by none other than Dave
Batista in the David Lynch film they all
had red hair razov he makes them all
bald that pale pasty look evokes the
royalty of old and in medieval times it
tended to show privilege this is why
elizabethans used to cake themselves in
makeup because the people who work jobs
in the sun often got a tan from it ban
of also wanted the Haw Onin to seem like
this because in the end reflected where
they were from it's a colorless world
with no natural light completely Bleak
and just black and white on the other
side of this rackus is bright and
vibrant with a first shot of spice
almost seeming like glitter and when
writing the book Lawrence of Arabia was
an influence on Herbert's work with a
lot of the characters being similar to
that H Zimmer ended up looking at a lot
of Middle Eastern music in order to
craft a soundtrack that he felt would be
accurate apparently he spent a week in
the deserts of Utah in order to listen
to the sound of the Wilderness and all
Al the brushing sand this helped him to
compose The Melodies and how he felt
that the piece should sound now zimmers
of course worked a lot with Christopher
noan but in the end he turned him down
on tenet this is because he was such a
big fan of June that he felt like it was
going to be a dream project now we
discover that though the har conans are
winning the emperor forced them to pull
back and here analyzed the plot he
realized they were richer and the atres
were more popular so kind of wanted them
to both take each other out from here we
could to pull waking up upon khedan and
get a flash of the air in the bottom
right it's important to know that this
is not a d and in the June Universe a
measure with ag this is AB the spacing
Guild was formed and Humanity moved into
the Stars no one knows exactly how that
translates to our time as the appendices
stay a number of different things the
universal calendar is 20 hours shorter
than Earth is and because they're not
set on Earth they also don't mention
things like leap years thus IMDb trivia
states that the movie takes place
roughly at 23,000 ad however again that
that might not be fully accurate and I
might be talking [__] and from here we
meet Paul's mother lady Jessica who's
not juk Leo's wife but instead it's just
a concubine the universe is very much
built on the patriarchy but there is a
female sect that also possess power that
is the Benny jeser who have some
political power and influence the name
is based on the Catholic order Jesuit
with Frank herberts and Brian confirming
that was the case the sister herd can do
things like the voice which would later
down the line influence Jedi mrix now
when the pair are getting a scor to the
desert one of the soldiers that does s's
death this is Steven Collins who was
picked on purpose by villain no because
this was something the voice would an
effect going back to those Greek
metaphors it's also clear that the Benny
are influenced by many things books in
natur pointed out they're a bit like the
sisters of fade who in themselves would
influence the NS he's also influenced
Star Wars as well with them being the
bases for the Sisters of damir now one
thing that I haven't mentioned yet is
spice allows you to pick the gender of
your child which is something they try
to use to get power but Millennia
they've influenced Bloodlines and
advised the houses on who they should
marry this was so they could create the
quiz at Tarak who's someone that would
be seen as the next Messiah the plan was
to have Jessica bear a daughter and this
would then marry into the HW conin their
child would then become the quad terak
unite the family and finally those
finally those Bloodlines that they'd all
pay off however Jessica she didn't care
through a spanner in the work and had a
boy because she loved the Juke who was
after a son he's made you look a right
knob she has to be fair and what was the
plan was basically the quizat would sit
on the throne and along with this they'd
get all the abilities you get from Spice
they could travel through space do all
of the Menat stuff have the Benny jeser
gifts and also hit the Thumbs Up Button
now it sounds pretty cool we we finally
got someone who can lead us however what
they'll really be doing is having
someone in charge that the Benny can PP
it round Herbert also recognized the
power of religion which is something
that Benny use as a weapon they realized
that if people believed a mass that this
man was the Messiah in the end they'd
follow him on a path they decided
Superstition and religion are used as a
way to control and thus this figure will
let them control the universe he' be the
most powerful being that ever existed
and will sit in the palm of their hands
the curve ball by Jessica is really
thrown them off and this is why they
need to test Paul this test can see
whether someone is an animal which is
how the Jess view most people they think
that animals won't be able to control
themselves and will act instinctively to
get away from danger thus only someone
with upper Consciousness can think of
the situation and hold their hand in
place to deal with the pain whether Paul
is the Messiah or whether he's just
believing his own hype is also something
that I think is deeply interesting and
of course love do your thoughts on that
below so whatever you think drop it in
the comments now it's also important to
know that Paul asks for water which in
itself will become a valuable commodity
from this point we then sees the
emperor's messenger arrives and can
catch lady Jessica wearing a Blue Dress
the circles on it are actually the Benny
jeser seal which also appears on the
dress of the one we see here the sort of
blue carpet rolls out the ship too with
blue of course being the color of water
the Menat gives the cost of the journey
three Guild Navigators a total of 1.46
million 62 Solaris round trip which is
done for a number of reasons you see it
not only shows how wealthy the emperor
is but it also adds pressure that the
duuk must accept though he knows it's
going to possibly lead to his end he
accepts because that's a thing to do and
from this point we meet Duncan Idaho
whose clothing of course resembles
modern fighter pilots his death is
something that hangs over Paul with him
envisioning it happen and then it coming
true in the dream we can catch a little
Beatle which is something Duncan picks
up before his death Duncan says dreams
make good stories but everything
important happens when we're awake cuz
that's when we make things happen which
I think is a very layered quote now huge
shout out to turnor C on Reddit who
broke down what this could mean they say
Paul's Vision show possible outcomes and
the closer he gets the more that he can
change them dreams can help you get a
glimpse into the future but it's only
when you're awake that you're able to
act Paul seeing dreams of himself dying
is the story of his death in which he
will then waking as the muad Juke then
explains what his goal is for oracus and
how it will actually make them even more
powerful here on kaladan we've ruled by
air power and sea power on araus we need
to cultivate desert power desert power
this plays off in the end with Paul
finally realizing he's able to attain
that desert
power this will mean that they have
complete control of all the necessary
resources and truly be the most powerful
house in the universe Paul wrestles back
and forth over whether he's the future
though and the dukee ends up showing him
his ring later when the dukee dies Paul
ends up wearing this showing how he's
now stepping closer to his Destiny now
from here we then meet gie HCK with Paul
mentioning how he recognizes his stride
we have to tell you tell us you by your
footsteps gie H someone might imitate my
stride this is some he touches upon
later when gie rescues him in the desert
I recognize your footsteps old man at
this point we get a demonstration of The
Shield which in the David Lynch films
were these these big blocky Tron things
here though they're completely
transparent except for when they get
struck by a weapon the way they work is
that if something strikes Fast and The
Shield is capable of blocking it
completely this is why guns are
completely useless because all it's
going to do is get blocked like you when
you say this video is mid [__] off
whenever we see the missiles of huny
seekers later on you'll notice I slow
down before hitting their target with a
blade you can also strike slower and
this is why we see them going through
the shield this is signified by turning
red and as we know red means dead his
fighting style was also developed by
Roger Yuan who based it on Filipino
martialarts this is refined and almost
like a dance oras the Hawkins are far
more brutal that was based on Mongolian
fighting styles to culturally show the
difference between the two now from here
we cut to gidy prime and come across
Baron har Conan morbidly obese he's now
at at the point where he has to use
anti-gravity Tech to propel him in the
air later they also allude heavily to
Apocalypse Now with his head rising out
the pool similar to Captain Willard
however he's definitely more in line
with Colonel Kurt who too often was seen
completely basked in Shadow in the scene
we watch him running his hand over his
head which is Su at Mar and Brando also
did there too in that film The Pool was
sort of like a baptism in which he arose
as something new with June it's almost
like him rising from black oil born
again after surviving the attack banov
said he saw the baron as a human in
Rhino form and rhinos of course also
take mud baths he realized that bringing
the cared alive was going to be what was
either going to make or break the movie
like Medieval Times They also looked at
figures there in order to go with how
they designed the fat suit being
overweight that used to symbolize
decadence in weth however there is a
reason for why this is the case might
spoil the next movie so we're just going
to skip her but either way they end up
covering him in Mist so you can imagine
how large he is at this point in the
Benny JZ go to Earth and we can see them
moving through a tunnel out in space
It's s that the space and Guild are
capable of Folding It which is something
we witness in this moment if you look
closely you'll notice a blue planet on
the other end of the tunnel which is
where the jeser have come from cutting
across the pole we once more see him
lying in bed with his shot echoing the
one from the beginning taking him out to
the gum Jabar test you can also see him
already pulling at his collar this could
be because he's already experienced this
in the previous dream and he knows of
the needle about to be at his neck you
then talks to him in Mandarin which at
this point is an old language from Earth
helps to show how well red Paul is and
how he studied several different
languages you also see Lady Jessica
start using sign language which in the
June world is called battle language
this was used so that communication
could be kept silent and not intercepted
by any spies or enemies it's also easily
recognizable with each simol being
abrupt and identifiable so there's no
confusion if you're in the fog of war in
the room we see the voice uted by the
Reverend mother which in itself carries
a lot of symbolism to it it shows that
Benny are capable of controlling Paul
and that if they need to he's going to
kneel before them kneeling of course
means to be subjugated letting us know
instantly who it is that's in charge we
also see what those affected by the
voice witness with it pretty much
becoming a blackout speaking of voices
Charlotte rampling plays the Reverend
mother and in real life the actress is
bilingual she actually ended up dubbing
herself in the French version so if you
swap the audio track you'll also hear
her there this is her try to test Paul
as much as possible because to her he
shouldn't have been born Jessica having
him has all to their plans but she still
holds out hope that he could end up
being the chosen one this is why she
later asks the baron to spare him
because otherwise it's going to throw
away Millennia of work we then get
what's the most famous quote in the book
which is fear is the m kill boil down to
its most basic terms it means that if
you give into fear it's going to end up
destroying you Fe can cause you to panic
and react without thinking which is
something that must resist though he
wants to pull his hand out he holds it
in place and bears through the pain even
though it's agonizing this is
symbolically shown by palm trees burning
and also seeing his hand turned to Ash
his sight is barely awakened and now he
goes into the fire these palm trees come
to burn at the hour 24 Mark showing us
how the prophecy was fulfilled we also
get a clip of his hand hovering above
sand symbolically representing how he
must pass this to embrace arus it's
important to bear in mind that when he
goes to the planet he doesn't actually
touch it until the scene with the worm
up until end he'd been wearing shoes and
stuff but this physical touch provides a
transformation cing to their ship we see
it rising from the water too which just
like a baptism shows they're going onto
something new Paul touches the grass
similar how he later touches the sand
which symbolizes his Farewell and his
new beginnings he also puts his hand
into a pool of water with sand sitting
below however he doesn't touch this
because he's not ready and it's only in
the rescue that he finally touches the
sunand lots of symbolism and also most
of these scenes were shot in Norway
which gives it a great contrast from
when they go to oracus that was shut out
in Jordan Abu Dhabi and the contrasting
environments really make these moments
pop and from this point we see Zan and
gurny says this quote my LS taste the
year of time past Fallen
sand this is a quote from the orange
Catholic Bible which is one of the most
popular religious texts in the entire
universe it fuses together the beliefs
of Christianity and Islam influences of
which can be seen throughout the film we
also get that annoying bagpipe player
that's brought into the schore and zimma
said during lockdown his daughter used
to kick off cuz sometimes he'd be
recording at 5: in the
morning just imagine that getting woken
up by that you wouldn't be happy H but I
know some people love it so if you do
let me know below now here for the first
time Paul Witnesses the crowd that's
gathered to see him and quickly realize
how much they've been brainwashed it's
kind of like when the beetles touchdown
and the fredman were told there'd be an
offwell profet who would lead them to
Victory the Benny jeser have just been
manipulating them the whole time and
Paving the way so Paul can take over we
then get to see the orops which are
designed to resemble dragonflies bugs
and insects were looked at closely by
the production team who all wanted to
take their design and adapt them into
this world the Haw con and helmets
purposely appear bug likee and there's
also the insect design in the Hunter
Seekers in nature dragonflies are
brilliant Navigators because their wings
allow them to in L switch flight modes
they can move quickly to lift and change
to hover with them also being able to
maneuver quickly if one moves faster
than the other these sort of wings can
do all of that and thus it makes it an
all round craft going back to those
Apocalypse Now motifs the flights also
Echo the helicopters in that beyond that
orus means bird in Greek again carrying
on this idea of the atres lineage we
then see them travel out to the Palace
which is of course based of pyramid
designs looking up into space we can
also catch the many moons especially
that distinctive one in the hand of God
beside it is also the muad which is a
Monica Paul later adopts the hand of God
being next to the muad could also
symbolically show the plan that's there
for Paul in reality this is simply just
a canyon pattern with them referencing
the one of Ms in order to create the
look for the 55 minute Mark Duncan gives
Paul a compass because the moon's
effects on the poles would send the
needle off course this highlights though
that he's going to act as a guide which
we will talk about later on in the video
now the M also makes another appearance
in the following scene when we see a
hologram of one inside a bush Jessica
then picks out a housekeeper and I love
how she goes for the badass in Mapes now
Mapes had gone to try and see if the
prophecies were true and if the atres
had indeed brought the Messiah however
Jessica also learned something as well
as she gets insight into the
Superstition that's being planted in the
culture mes is overcome with crying
religiously calm down and it shows how
much he trusts her you in the knife
is tooth of
shy this basically translate to sandworm
tooth showing how Paul will later
embrace them to help win the war now
from here we cut to the pilgrims
worshipping the trees which are watered
daily to keep them alive each dring the
equivalent of 5 men a day and it
showcases how much tradition can often
leave others struggling I don't know if
it's a common on royalty or just
worshipping in general but we see they
happily sacrifice their own needs to
keep up the tradition now Paul is then
attacked by a huny and I love how we see
the one who enabled it was hidden in the
palace walls this is something that
always stuck with me in the book cuz
this guy would have basically had to
cement himself in here he'd lie and wait
until they arrived and only get the one
chance to take out his Target Paul
manages to survive by remaining
completely still because he knows a
hunter seeker's Visions based solely on
movement this is him once more showing
his mindset with a G Jabar in which he's
able to think and not immediately Panic
this is also needed across the surface
of oracus as one must move without
Rhythm to not alert the sand worms one
may end up panicking and running but
then all it's going to do is lead them
to their death now I know I said earlier
that they don't use robots so you're
probably thinking so that was a [__]
lie all about the world of June does in
fact use machines but nothing that's
able to go above its station this keeps
a eye on a rung below the humans and
therefore they can never overthrow them
now with a baron we see he's got a
spider-like creature that's also
possessing creepy human hands no idea
what's going on with this as it's
something brand new made up for the
movie but in the source material The
Baron's pets were all young boys I'm
getting the
word NS so maybe they didn't want to put
that in the film but either way there's
no alien races in June unless you count
the sand whims all the creatures we see
are caused by spice with this spider
creature potentially being immune from
that there's also a fan Theory by Ronald
MC big dick on Reddit yep that that's
her name Ronald MC big dick Theory by
them anyway that this is the Benny TCS
in the book there SP nice enhanced
humans that have isolated themselves
from the rest of the universe they
created some of the scariest creatures
in the June universe and also had a hand
in Peter D re in this movie he's played
by David Das Malin making this his third
team with billan actually think he's
died in all his films with those being
prisoner Blade Runner 2049 and later on
in this though not spelled out in the
film it was deze who suggested the baron
that they kidnapped dror U's wife and he
was the one who decided they should kill
her you can see a diamond symbol located
on U's head and this indicates that he's
one of the Suk doctors this tattoo marks
them as people who can't betray their
patients or break their hypocritic o
that they've sworn to the houses however
he figured out they could hold his wife
and he'd go against it which leads to
this really chilling line they take her
apart like a doll going to a meeting we
then get gurnie seeing this let shall
suck at the abundance of the Seas on the
treasure hi in the sand this is a quote
from Elder William bruer who was a
leader of the Plymouth Colony you thank
the Lord for some clams during a famine
and it highlights how they've all been
left with the scraps now my favorite
quote from a holy figure is I don't like
sand which is pretty much everyone's
mood for this movie and we then travel
out to the spice silos which are a far
cry from how many the har conans had in
that opening Montage we learn that
they've removed most of their equipment
and I've only left behind the the really
[__] machines they're obviously also
planning an attack so would want to get
their best stuff out the way and then
bring it back to the planet at this
point we then meet star reuniting two
characters from No Country for all men
breakdown of that on the channel now and
we see as he spits when he greets them
in any other culture this would be taken
as an insult but with the fman it has
the utmost respect their entire
existence is about preserving water and
thus spitting could be very costly to
them Stelar carries to still scores on
his face which were done by the
production team to show his History of
Violence at this point we meet leak kind
who he learns been working for the
emperor however she's also been helping
the fman secretly so one day they can be
free this will allow them to terraform
the planet and live on the surface with
an abundance of water huge shout outs
again to books and nachos who went into
why Herbert created this character
apparently he was a reporter out in
Oregon who was going over a story about
a cists working with the beach the Sands
have been blowing up and destroying the
farmlands making it near impossible for
food to be grown ecologists were trying
to introduce beach grass and this in the
end would slow and delay the effects BOS
brought up how he saw civilization could
be swallowed by the desert and he wanted
an ecologist who could help save the day
which ends up giving them their still
suits which recycle their sweat into
drinkable water out in the desert we get
the rescue scene with a harvester crew
and this helps to give us lots of
different things firstly the machines
are lifted by balloons because if they
made their entire Journey on land they
would just attract the worms it also
shows that Paul will try and save people
R the Hawkins would have just let them
die gives him his first encounter with
spice and he also Witnesses the giant
worms up close the first time spice hits
them we also get a line showing that the
quiz had had around has now been
awakened AIT now when designing the
worms villain of spier concepting the
creatures and they dove into every
detail on the Beast whether it was the
texture of the skin or how it eats food
they really wanted to give an
authenticity to it VFX supervisor Paul
Lambert studied the movement of whales
and also their mouths which we can see
in their teeth whales have Bine which
help them to filter food which is also
something they brought across to the
worm when crafting the scene they ALS
had sand mimic the movement of water
giving a feeling of seeing a whale
rising from the ocean going with a beast
that looks prehistoric the worms are
beautiful but also completely terrifying
obviously this movie needs a lot of EFX
but the creative team did something that
rarely ever happens instead of using
green screen they actually used sand
screen so the environment around the
actors appeared more natural I watch
this movie with a Philips Hite hooked up
and you can see it just beaming Browns
oranges and yellows really makes this
whole thing pop and add a distinctive
look to the whole of oracus and back in
his room Paul explains the vision of
channy stabbing him and you might start
to wonder what what's going on well this
is really her giving him the Chris knife
and the stabbings because it's killing
his past self amongst this he also sees
his mother pregnant and giving birth to
his little sister Alia can't talk about
her too much as she's a major thing in
part two but I like that they're at
least laying the groundwork one thing
that I found out in my research as well
is that Rebecca Ferguson she's only
actually 12 years older than shalom
still out never crossed my mind and I
think they made it feel like there was a
much bigger age capap and from here we
cut to salusa sakundes which is the home
of the might seduka the seduka or soduku
I always end up calling them they're
known as the most fearsome Army in the
universe but Paul ends up realizing the
fman are stronger in order to survive on
oracus one has to be built different and
this is why they're capable of beating
them we then see them getting anointed
before battle in what's almost like a
religious ceremony passed by priestesses
they place a thumb with blood on their
head which is similar to what priests
and vicar do for blessings you can also
catch their wrists seem like they're
wearing rosary beads and we get further
religious imagery with where the blood
comes from this is drained from men that
have been crucified upside down and you
can see as their blood runs into a Troth
we can also hear that distinctive throat
singing again which is based on
techniques from Mongolia and Tibet the
city is in attack with UA lowering the
Shields and the Duke is sadly betrayed
before he's then captured he sees a
light flashing in the desert signaling
to commend and then finds that Mapes has
been stabbed in the scene right before
this he also met with Jessica and
clearly knew that something was going to
happen during this we C to the bull
sculpture highlighting what this fight
is really for in the battle we can see
gie running head into it and can also
catch Duncan Idaho clashing with the
soldiers at one point he Taps the
anti-gravity thing on his belt and just
like the baron this helps him to float
he ends up stealing an ornithopter and I
love how he just kind of scares some
soldiers away after killing a handful
such a badass and at this point l lady
Jessica and Paul are taken to the desert
which is where they're going to be left
to die you might be wondering how they
get their equipment but there is a
little clue given to us in the orop
there Jessica spots a pole that is a
little Diamond etched into it and this
is the symbol of Dr UA underneath it is
a little kid and this has the tent and
the equipment within it inside that tent
they also find a roll of paper once more
with Dr UA's symbol UA of course also
helps the Juke and even though he
betrays him he gives him a way to get
revenge this is sort of still keeping
his oath well not really but at least he
aided them in the end also I love the
way how we see the voices used here and
Jessica even bites down on one of the
Gods fingers again it highlights how
powerful her mouth is and how it can be
used as a weapon which careful guys
careful at this point the baron meets
with a Juke and Leo ends up staring at a
bullhead this is just like what his
father saw before he faced death but he
went out fighting like the Juke does
here also I realized when I've been
recording this I've been calling him
Duke Leto and then I was like I think it
might be lato too so apologize for being
an idiot I have that same issue with
Jared Leto where I'm like is it Leto is
it leato I don't know H but yeah the
pronunciation again it's it's not going
to be too accurate but it's too late to
change it so just leave leave out the
comments please now from here we see is
the baron also calls some cousin no
future spoilers but yeah we'll probably
learn about the mess up lineage during
part two but what the baron did during
this the Reverend mother ended up
cursing him and thus he ended up with
his China Beast body Juke then Witnesses
him hovering above the table and
oh they fly now they fly
now they fly now after killing UA the
dock gets the baron coming closer and
it's at this point he releases the gas
the reason why this is chosen as a
weapon is because it's something that
can Infiltrate The Shield this moment
Paul and Jessica also discover his ring
which U left him as his final gift it
shows that he's dead and with his father
gone Paul must now step up and take over
his lead we then cut from Paul's hand
down to his father and last see the ball
looking down on them at this moment Paul
has a vision of the future in which he
leads an Unholy War Across the Universe
we can see here that he's mastered the
sand worms and a similar shots going to
be used in part two with channy after
witnessing a bloody hand he then sees a
journey back to kaladin where we can see
him joined by channy and also jamas to
the right this again shows the future
could be changed with it suggesting that
Paul may still have control this future
will likely be explored in Du Messiah
which shows how religion can be used as
a weapon we can also catch Paul's eyes
glowing blue the effects of these being
done with bfx initially they wanted to
just use contact lenses but quickly
realized how much trouble it was going
to be the desert of course would keep
kicking sand up in your eyes and in the
end they just went with CGI a Darth maze
on Reddit caught some amazing symbolism
in this moment as we get a closeup of
the water tubes on the tent these look
like veins and blood making this tent
almost appear womb likee Paul an emerges
like he's reborn and the first thing he
sees is that little mu Adib this
symbolizes the new change within him and
he's now being born under that monik the
little mouse is also perfectly evolved
to be some that survives in this harsh
desert landscape this is a symbol of
endurance which is something that Paul
will also come to represent rescued by
Duncan and Dr KES they then travel out
to a fing Outpost that was meant to
change the planet to a paradise however
this was later abandoned but it might be
something that pops up in the future
Duncan also pays close attention to the
plans which may H at something that
happens in the sequel also I'm skipping
over a line here in which Paul a Jess
making a play as again future spoilers
what you mean it's a heavy spoiler sh I
should tell you all well you're going to
have to wait mate it's coming out soon
either way Duncan dies here and the
sakar arrive in what's a really cool
moment just love seeing them float down
silently but the fredman are waiting
here with an ambush this highlights how
they can stand against them and use the
power of the desert but right now
they're just not good enough they need a
leader and everyone knows that so both
KES and Duncan try and bip time KES ends
up using sing a thumper and the sound of
this is almost like a beating heart with
worms being like blood that moves
through the veins of the planet this is
also like how the movie opens and after
the logos we can hear it thumping
[Music]
away we see Ken readying her hooks but
unfortunately she never gets to ride the
worm as we see at the end though there
are worm Riders out there and this will
become something bigger later on I think
they did this here to just tease what
would come but wanted to say the first
major ride for that upcoming sequel also
I love how as she gets stabbed in the
back you can actually catch water
spurting out the suit instead of being
blood this also drips into her hand as
she lies on the ground which is such a
cool way to change what we typically see
beating the way for the worm we then see
as her all engulf showing what the true
power here is now Paul and Jessica then
Escape Into the Storm and after a lesson
from Jamis Paul learns to let go this is
him realizing fear is the mind killer
and th he decides not to panic at this
point we then cted the baron and healing
and he says kill them all again going
back to the colonel Kurt similarities
this could be a nod to his final order
will it ended up coming across his notes
and scribbled on them it said
exterminate them all we already have a
big breakdown on apocalypse now so if
you want to check that out it's on the
channel as well now with Paul and
Jessica we see as they crash and come
face to face with a worm Paul ended up
panicking in the end and running and it
shows that he truly hasn't mastered
everything he ends up making it to the
rocks and the worm then pauses all
almost like a sign of respect kind of
strikes me as being like Paul staring
into the abyss and in it realizing what
he is the mouth beats away like a heart
again tying back to this idea of a
thump taken in by the fman he then sees
a vision of Duncan sitting on the rock
that the pair have just passed like him
he ended up integrated into the group
and this not only shows Duncan's P but
also PA's future to me this showcas is
how Duncan still guiding force to him
showing him the possibility if they
become allies you also get a moment
where channy shows him in M showing that
if it can survive here then Paul can
survive too jamus here also appears like
a mentor again which further highlights
how the future can be changed jamisen
calls the anti challenge with a final
fight being between him and Paul now
jamus the reason why he's such a dick
like you may is because he wants to see
if the prophecy is true he basically
assumes that Paul and Jessica are
spoiled Rich Chums and sees them both as
being easy wins little does he know
though kids being trained by some of the
best fighters in the universe and
therefore he makes mince me of jamas see
a chump Shanny gives him the Chris knife
and we see that this s has a diamond on
it again playing into the idea that this
gives way to something helpful Paul ends
are Bing Jamis pretty easily and we
seees he puts a blade up to his neck
this is in order to get him to yield but
it's also something that gurnie halik
taught him calling back to that battle
at the beginning this was also move Paul
out to try and end the fight and it both
failed and it leads to Paul killing him
to take that next PATH that will lead
into him getting desert
power which brings things full circle
from the beginning now we see Paul
heading towards the worm instead of
running away because this will be the
weapon that helps win the war he will
become a rider a mentor and also someone
who liked the spacing guilds able to
fold time and space he also knows the
ways of the Benny jeser and in the end
will be the Supreme Being anyway that
closes out June part one and thank you
for coming on this journey as for the
film's performance I'm sure you already
know but this was dropped as a day one
on HBO Max it's a bold strategy cotton
let's see if it pays off for them and it
caused lots of issues with legendary and
villain of who was pretty annoyed by it
he said that a film like this should be
experienced in the cinema with streaming
just being something that palis in
comparison bloody hell though mate I've
got a got a 60in 4K OLED and an Atmos
set what you what are you talking about
[__] off anyway he also criticized the
piracy potential and I think in
hindsight it was a bad move that was
what maid Nolan walk away from Warner
Brothers and the worst thing is they
didn't even Warner Brother he shoed his
next film up andhe out universal and in
the end we know how that did at the box
office though June made 400 million and
this was coming off the back of 165 made
41 million openening weekend in beat
Godzilla versus Kong which had 31 on
streaming it was watched by 400 million
in the first 30 days and it led to it
being a pretty big success that's why
Warner Brothers were so confident with
part two and there's also Rumblings of
an upcoming te show either way we're
going to see what happens next and I
hope you've enjoyed our trip out to
oracus we do breakdowns like this every
week and if you've enjoyed it please hit
subscribe if you're feeling extra
generous and please click the join
button where you'll get early access to
all of our big breakdowns that cost just
99 P or 99 cents a month and it's a sort
of give what you can thing where we're
trying that out for new people who want
to help the channel I really don't want
to ask people to break the bang and yeah
just that little amount of month goes a
long way for videos like this and next
we're going to be tackling the Wicker
man and we of course also be diving into
June part two think I'm going to do an
ending explain and then when it finally
drops digitally do a big in-depth
breakdown just easier when I have it at
home at hand to watch and also I'd love
to hear your thoughts and if there's
anything we missed then please drop a
below make sure you also check out our
arrival breakdowns and no country
referral men which will be linked on
screen right now out the way thank you
for clicking this I've been Paul you've
been the best I'll see you next time
take care
peace